개인적인 생각 제가 너무
열받아서 빌사남의
노크 안녕하세요 빌사남의 노크
김현수입니다 저희 오늘 세 번째 모실
게스트는 저희 회사의 에이스인 완준
중계사 님을 모셨습니다 완준 중개사님
나와주세요
안녕하세요 녕 세네 아 저희 그
구독자들을 위해서 간단하게 소개
부탁드리겠습니다 안녕하십니까 bsn
미사남 전완준 중개사입니다 완준
중계사 님은 우리 회사에서 제가 봤을
때 일단 제일 일찍 출근하세요 물론
이제 제가 문을 열긴 하지만
그다음으로 출근하는게 저희 완준
중계사 님인데 정말 성실하고 일을
열심히 하는 중계사 님이라고 생각들고
앞으로 더 잘 되시지 않을까네 이렇게
생각을 하고 있습니다 일단 오늘
본격적으로 사연을 한번 읽어 주세요
네 안녕하세요 저는 현재 가로수길에
150억 정도의 건물을 보유하고 있는
건물주입니다 현재 임대 시장이 너무
안 좋은데 가로수길에 이제 또 일조건
규제 완화라는 호재 소식도 있잖아요
그리고 또 상권은 또 돌고 도니까
가지고 있어야 되나 싶기도 하고 계속
임대가 안 맞춰지다 보니까 이걸
어떻게 해야 할지 고민이 너무
많은데요 작년 5월에 잔금을 마치고
지금 현재 2월까지 계속 공실이
지속되다 보니까 스트레스가 이만저만이
아니네요 건물 물의 공시를 해결하려면
어떻게 해야 할까요 가지고 있는게
나을까요 아니면 손해 보고 팔더라도
다른 곳을 들어가는게 나을까요
앞으로의 전망 부탁드릴게요 어 일단
요즘 가로수길 상권이 좀 어떤 거
같으세요 사실 아직까지 가로수길
공실이 워낙 많고 하다 보니까
성간적색화
있고 진짜 유명한 브랜드 많이 들어와
있고 근데 지금은 반 이상이 다 나가
있고 지금 어떻게 보면 가로스 상황은
좀 최악의 상황이 아닐까네 이렇게
생각을 합니다 그래서요 건물 같은
경우에도 공실이 거의 9개월 정도
유지되고 있는데 진짜 손해 보고 팔고
다른 곳에 아니면 투자하는게 나을지
그런 부분에 대해서 어떻게 생각하세요
사실 이제 저희가 사연만 듣다 보니까
건물에 뭐 정확한 뭐 스펙이라는
위치나 이런 건 정확히 모르겠지만은
소유주께서 현실적으로 좀 저렴한 임대
료를 받아서 유지할 수 있다고 하면은
지금 상황은 되게 안 좋지만
장기적으로 좀 가져갈 수 있다고
하면은 어느 순간에 좀 회복되는
순간은 올 거라고 생각이 들긴
하거든요 그리고 이제 금액 볼륨
자체도 이제 150억 정도 수준이다
보니까 그 정도 볼륨에서 이제 다른
대체제를 찾기에는 이분이 매입했을 때
이제 결정했었다 선택지라 그다음에
다른 또 선택지를 고려했을 때도
마음에 내킬 만한 선택지가 크게 없을
것 같긴 해 가지고 그래도 만약에
혹시 이제 대출 이자나 이런게 좀
감당이 가능한 수준이라고 하면은
중장기적으로 좀 보유하실 수 있으면
좋지 않을까 싶습니다 제가 봤을 때는
가로 스킬이라고 돼 있는데 사실 가로
세로 스킬이 아니면 나로 스킬 쪽이냐
뭐 그런 거에 따라서 또 달라질 것
같고 지금 상황이 워낙 좋지 않다
보니까 팔기도 쉽지 않을 것 같아
처음에 그거 들어갈 때부터 그걸
감안하고 투자를 했어야죠 사실 그리고
만약에 매각한다고 했을 때 좀 손해
보거나 이런 확률이 좀 되게 높다라고
생각은 합니다 버틸 수 있으면
버티는게 제일 중요하고 진짜
2010년 도 초반만 하더라도 앞구정
로데오 이랬거든요네 압구정 로데오 다
비어 있고 임차 너무 안 차고 빌딩도
잘 매각이 안 되고 그랬었는데 거기
이제 되게 유명한 이렇게 임차인들이
막 들어오면서 이제 분위기가 좀
바뀌기 시작했고 그러면서 되게
좋아졌는데 그리고 지금 임대료 수준이
되게 높아요 그래서 그런 것도 조금
조정을 하고 괜찮은 임차인이 좀
들어오고 한다라고 하면은 충분히 다시
살아날 그런 여지도 있지 않을까네
이렇게 예상을 하고 있습니다 그리고
만약에 이제 건물을 판다라고 했을 때
다른 지역으로 혹시 추천한다면 어디를
좀 추천하고 싶으세요 지금이 분께서는
아무래도 공실에 대한 우려가 가장
커서 매각도 이제 고려를 하시는
거잖아요 그러다 보니까 아무래도 좀
공실 리스크가 덜한 지역을 추천드리고
싶은데 테란로 같은 업무시설 밀집
지역이라는 경기나 이런 것들을 또
타긴 하지만 그래도 꾸준하게 임대
수요가 있는 사장님이 좋아하시는 뭐
이제 공원뷰 끼고 있는 라인이라던지
뭐 요런 쪽에서는 그래도 지속적으로
임대 수요가 있다 보니까 아무래도
상대적으로 공실이 덜하다고 생각되거든
그런 지역들을 좀 추천드리고 싶습니다
저는 앞으로도이 상권도 되게 양극화될
거 같아요 그래서 바글바글한 데는
바글바글하고 비어 있는데 비어 있고
제가 영상에도 많이 말씀드렸던 지역들
그런 지역들로 더 몰리지 않을까
이렇게 생각을 합니다 공시를 해결할
수 있는 뭔가 방법이 있으세요 본인의
기대치보다는 현재 시장에서 받아줄 수
있을 만한 적정 수준의 임대료 파악
일단 1순위인 거 같고요 두 번째로
이제 저희 건물 인근에 이제 있는
경쟁 건물들이 있잖아요 뭐 규모라는
연식이 그지 컨디션이라 이런 경쟁
건물들을 봤을 때 거기에 있는
건물들은 왜 이제 임차가 들어갔는지
뭐 이런 거에 대한 좀 좀 어필할 수
있는 그런 포인트들을 좀 잡아
주시는게 좋을 것 같아요 그래야지
이제 매물들이 많다 보니까 다양한
매물들을 추천드리는데 특정 건물만의
가격이라는 내부 마감이라는 이런 좀
경쟁력이 있을 만한 요소가 있다고
하면은 추천드린 입장에서도 어필할 수
있는 포인트가 될 거라고 생각
들거든요 이런 것들도 한번 고민해
보시면 좋을 것 같습니다 사실 이렇게
적정 가격으로 하는게 제일 중요한 거
같고 그리고 저는 항상 얘기하는게
이거 어떻게 보면 사업이 든요 그런
사업과 마인드로 좀 차별화가 있고
가격적으로 메리트가 있거나 그런 거를
생각하고 하시면 좋을 거 같고 제가
지금이 상황이다 하면은 일단 일조건
해제가 됐기 때문에 공사를 할 거
같아요 일조권이 사실 이렇게 피냐
마냐가 진짜 건물 가치가 워낙
달라지고 그리고 임대료 수준이 워낙
달라지기 때문에 지금 건물이 비어
있을 때 일조건 사선 받은 부분을
반듯하게 폈을 때 비용이라든지 얼마나
늘어나는지 조금 체크할 거 같아요
나중에 뭐 매각하기에 사실 이렇게
피는게 훨씬 낫거든요네 제 생각에는
어찌됐든 지금 가로 스킬에 뭐 일조건
완화가 진짜 엄청나게 큰 메리트라고
저는 생각해서 지금 일단 뭐 비어
있으니까 뭐 비용이 들긴 하겠지만
그것까지 생각을 해서 최대한 좀
효율성을 높이는 쪽으로 하는게 전
좋은 거 같아요 이게 사실 일조건
받으면 저는 제 조건이 없어이
얘기해도 되나 물론 이제 햇빛을
받아야 된다 뭐 이런 취지에서 너무
동일 하는데 미국처럼 공중권 이렇게
사고 팔고 풀어졌을 때 확실히
풀어주고 무조건 주차장 확보 때문에
막 1층 다 깨져 있고 개인적인
생각이 좀 너무 좀 그래요 도산대로
막 보면은 예전에 허가 받은 건
800% 받긴 했지만 일조건 받은 건
다 이렇게 생겼잖아요음 맞습니다 송원
빌딩이 난 너무 아까워 그게 좋은
땅에
개인적인 생각 제가 너무 열받아서
저는 일단은 롯데 타워를 계속 얘기했
대요 저 롯데 타워가 진짜 롯데 타워
없었으면 제 우리나라 큰일 나왔지
555m 되는 그런 빌딩이 세계적으로
다섯 번째 수준의 높은 빌딩이고 정말
그 빌딩 없었으면 진짜 어 너무
규제도 많고 이게 너무 막이 돈의
예산에 맞춰서 뭐 하려니까 그죠 그죠
아이 좀 안타깝긴 합니다 네 그래서
오늘 완준 중계사 님이랑 좀 얘기해
봤는데 좀 어떠셨어요 또 다시 한번
가로수길이나 이런데 한번 고민해 보게
됐는데 이쪽이 아직까지도 워낙 공실이
많다 보니까이 사연 주신뿐만 아니라
비슷하게 이제 가로수길 이외에도
공실로 인해서 좀 고민이신 분들이
많을 것이라고 생각이 들어요 그런
분들도 오늘이 영상 좀 참고하셔
가지고 임대에 대해서 좀 어떤 식으로
좀 개선해 볼 수 있을지 한번 생각해
볼 수 있는 시간이었으면 좋겠습니다
임대가 요즘 워낙 어렵고 지금 가로
스킬뿐만 아니라 다른데도 워 많이 비
있고 내가 사업한다는 생각으로
공격적으로 가격을 확 낮추던지 아니면
렌트 풀리를 엄청 추든지 아니면
인테리어 비용을 제공하지 아니면 내
건물을 정말 멋있게 만들든지 뭔가
그런 차별화된 전략 뭐 이런 거를 좀
세워 가지고 지금 시기를 어쨌든 잘
버티는게 중요하다라고 저는 생각을
합니다 여러분들 제가 계속 사연을
받고 있는데 만약 궁금한게 있으시다고
하면 저희 뭐 메일 보내주셔도 되고
아니면 댓글로 남겨 주시면 제가 그걸
하나 선정해 가지고 다음 콘텐츠로
촬영하도록 하겠습니다 여기까지
하겠습니다
안녕
똑똑 어서
[음악]